I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hey, everybody! Hi, you guys! This week we are talking about the Convict Season 3 Episode 9 written by Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant and directed by Jeffrey Blitz. There's some powerhouse there. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Well, I'm wasting no time. I'm gonna hit you with a summary. Hit me, baby, one more time. Oh,
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士们。大家好！嗨，你们好！本周我们讨论的是第三季第九集《罪犯》，由瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·麦克商编剧，杰弗里·布利茨执导。那里有一些非常厉害的人物。哦，是的。哦，是的。哦，是的。好吧，我绝不浪费时间。我直接用总结来轰炸你。再爱我一次，宝贝。哦，
baby. Just give me a summary. Oh, my God. Oh, Brittany, we love you. All right. In this episode, Michael learns that one of the new Stanford transfers, Martin Nash, is a reformed convict. When Martin tells the other employees about his time in prison, the staff says it sounds like it's better than working at Dunder Mifflin. Well, Michael is heartbroken to hear that people would rather be in prison than at Dunder Mifflin. So he responds by turning into prison Mike to scare them all straight. And then also, Andy asks Jim for advice on how to whoop ham. And we get a little bit of a prank. He's gonna whoop ham. There's gonna be some banjo
宝贝。快给我一个总结。哦，天哪。哦，布兰妮，我们爱你。好吧。在本集里，迈克尔得知斯坦福来的新转调员工之一马丁·纳什是个改过自新的罪犯。当马丁向其他员工讲述他的铁窗生涯时，员工们说听起来比在邓德·米夫林工作还要好。好吧，迈克尔听到人们宁愿坐牢也不愿留在邓德·米夫林，心碎不已。于是他的反应是变成监狱迈克来吓唬他们走上正轨。然后还有，安迪向吉姆请教如何痛扁火腿。我们还得了一点恶作剧。他要痛扁火腿。会有些班卓琴
playing. It's a real special. Jenna, I know you're about to hit me with some fast facts, but I bet I can guess two of them. Hit you with some fast facts. Oh, no. Right now, we're hitting fast forward. They're like, please, can I skip past them doing Britney Spears? Is your first fast fact that Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant created the office for the BBC? They're the OG of the OG? Yes, Angela. It is. Yes. And also, this is the only episode of the American Office that was written by Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant. I didn't know that. Well, our pilot was sort of technically written by them because, yeah, we really, we used so
演奏。这真是一集特别节目。珍娜，我知道你准备用一些快讯来轰炸我，但我敢打赌我能猜中其中两个。用快讯轰炸你。哦，不。现在，我们要按快进键了。他们大概在想，求求了，我能跳过他们模仿布兰妮·斯皮尔斯吗？你的第一个快讯是不是瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·麦克商为BBC创作了《办公室》？他们是始祖中的始祖？是的，安吉拉。正是如此。是的。而且，这也是美国版《办公室》中唯一一集由瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·麦克商编剧的剧集。我不知道这个。好吧，我们的试播集其实在技术上也算是他们写的，因为，是的，我们真的，我们用了
much of it, but it was also adapted by Greg Daniels. But this is the only original American office that they wrote. Now, Stephen did direct an episode. He directed customer survey in season five, and Ricky did a cameo in season seven. And they were around. They would come visit us. I remember Stephen Merchant being in the writer's room a lot. Yeah. He would come by whenever he was in America. And you know, Angela, I did a movie with Stephen Merchant. You did a movie with the tall man from England? Yes. It was called Hall Pass. Oh. And it was a Farrelly Brothers movie. It shot in Atlanta, and I was so happy that Stephen
那么多他们的内容，但它也是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯改编的。但这是他们写的唯一原创的美国版《办公室》。现在，斯蒂芬确实指导过一集。他导演了第五季的《客户调查》，瑞奇在第七季客串过。他们都在附近。他们会来看望我们。我记得斯蒂芬·麦克商经常在编剧室里。是的。他只要在美国就会顺道过来。你知道的，安吉拉，我和斯蒂芬·麦克商拍过一部电影。你跟那个来自英国的高个子男人拍过电影？是的。它叫《嘿咻卡》。哦。这是一部法拉利兄弟的电影。在亚特兰大拍摄的，我太高兴斯蒂芬
Merchant was on this movie because this movie had like these huge powerhouse comedic stars. Okay. It was Owen Wilson. There was Jason Sedakis, JB Smoove, Christina Applegate, and then like me. I remember. I remember you going off to do this and you were like, oh my god, I'm so nervous. I'm so nervous. I was so happy that I knew someone. Yeah. So I kind of glommed on to Stephen Merchant when we were on that set because I was like someone I know. Because otherwise, when you go do those movies, I always feel like the new kid in school where it's like, where do I fit in? I don't know anyone. Yeah. I was so nervous. But there
麦克商能参演这部电影了，因为这部电影有这些超级强大的喜剧明星阵容。好吧。有欧文·威尔逊。有杰森·苏戴奇斯，JB·斯穆夫，克莉丝汀·阿普加特，然后就像我。我记得。我记得你出发去拍这个的时候，你说，哦，天哪，我好紧张。我好紧张。我很高兴我认识人。是的。所以我有点黏上了斯蒂芬·麦克商，当我们在那个片场的时候，因为我想，总算有个我认识的人了。因为除此之外，当你去拍那些电影时，我总是觉得自己像学校里的新生，心想：我该怎么融入？我谁也不认识。是的。我太紧张了。但
was another reason why I was very nervous on this movie, and it was because I was staying in a haunted hotel. What? Yes. You remember this? No. Lady. Yes. I got to Atlanta and they put me up in this hotel. I would get woken up in the middle of the night at like 2 30 in the morning by the sound of clumpy footsteps on my ceiling. Well, that happens in hotels, lady. Does it happen when your hotel room is on the top floor and there's nothing above you? What? No. I was on the top floor. So I called down to the front desk and I was like, excuse me. Do you guys do maintenance on the roof at like 2 30 in the morning? Are people walking on the
我在这部电影里感到非常紧张还有另一个原因，那就是我住在一个闹鬼的酒店里。什么？是的。你还记得这个吗？不。我的天。是的。我到了亚特兰大，他们把我安排在这家酒店。我半夜会在两点半左右被天花板上沉重的脚步声惊醒。好吧，酒店里经常发生这种事，我的天。当你住的酒店房间在顶楼，而你上面空无一物时，这也会发生吗？什么？没有。我在顶楼。所以我打电话给前台，我说，不好意思。你们会在半夜两点半左右在屋顶进行维护吗？有人在
roof? What? Well, the person on the phone was like, no. And also just because you're on the top floor, they're like, that doesn't mean that like your ceiling is literally the roof of the building. Like there's stuff in between. What? The ceiling of your hotel. Like a secret floor? That's what I said. Yes. I said, what's happening there? Like when you get to an elevator and there's no button for it? Yes. That's what I wanted to know. What is happening in this space? Something is happening. People are walking. They insisted that I was not hearing these noises. They insisted. Angela, I wouldn't let it go. Well, so I
屋顶走动吗？什么？好吧，电话那头的人说，没有。而且，就算你住在顶楼，他们也说，这并不意味着你的天花板字面意思就是建筑物的屋顶。就像中间还有其他东西一样。什么？你的酒店天花板。就像一个秘密楼层？我是这么说的。是的。我说，那里面到底发生了什么？就像当你走到电梯前却没有它的按钮一样？是的。这就是我想知道的。这个空间里到底发生了什么？一定有什么事情在发生。有人在走动。他们坚称我没有听到这些声音。他们坚称。安吉拉，我就是不肯罢休。好吧，所以我
went to a travel website and I googled this hotel. You did a deep dive on the hotel. It's a haunted hotel. No. There were tons of stories of people who had stayed on the top floor who had heard the footsteps. Shut the front door. Okay. So now I can't sleep, right? Because you have a full-on ghost. I'm in a ghost hotel. I have to go to work tomorrow with Owen Wilson. I'm sleepless. I'm nervous. I called Lee crying in the middle of the night. Lee, who was my boyfriend at the time, who's back in Los Angeles writing a script, I was like, you need to fly here and you have to come keep me safe from the ghosts. You have to stay with
去了一个旅游网站，谷歌了这家酒店。你对这家酒店进行了深度挖掘。这是一家闹鬼的酒店。不。有成千上万的故事说，住在顶楼的人都听到过脚步声。我的老天爷啊。好吧，所以我现在睡不着了，对吧？因为你遇到了一个彻头彻尾的幽灵。我住在一个鬼酒店里。我明天还要跟欧文·威尔逊一起去上班。我失眠了。我很紧张。我在半夜哭着打电话给李。李，他是我当时的男朋友，当时在洛杉矶写剧本，我说，你必须飞到这里来，你必须来保护我免受鬼魂侵害。你必须留下来
me during this movie. And he's like, what am I a ghost buster? What the heck? Jenna, just move hotels. That's what Lee said. But I was like, I am not about to call this production company and insist that they move me from this hotel because it's haunted. They would think you were Looney Tunes. They would be like, oh, this actress is convinced her hotel room is haunted and she wants to move. I get it. I get it. So Lee flew out. He stayed with me while I shot that movie and protected me from the ghosts. And by the way, when he got there, he heard it. He heard it. I would be so freaked out. Well, oh my gosh, that fast fact took a turn.
在这部电影拍摄期间陪着我。他说，我是什么捉鬼敢死队吗？搞什么鬼？珍娜，换个酒店不就行了。李就是这么说的。但我当时想，我才不要打电话给这家制作公司，坚持要求他们给我换酒店，就因为这里闹鬼。他们会觉得你疯了。他们会想，哦，这个女演员确信她的酒店房间闹鬼，她想换房间。我懂，我懂。所以李飞了过来。我拍那部电影的时候他一直陪着我，保护我免受鬼魂侵害。顺便说一句，他到那儿之后，他也听到了。他听到了。我要吓死了。好吧，哦天哪，那个快讯来了个大转弯。
But I like it. It really did. I'm here for it. I'm gonna steer us back onto the episode with fast fact number two. This was the first episode directed by Jeff Blitz. We love Jeff Blitz. He directed 11 episodes of The Office. This was his first. He is a wonderful, delightful human being. I adore him. We reached out to Jeff and he sent in audio clips about this episode. We're so excited. I also told him I really need him to come back on because we need to discuss Save Bandit. Yes. And when I threw that cat in the ceiling, that has to be talked about. Because he directed that episode too, right? Yes. But you guys, I want to give a
但我喜欢。确实如此。我举双手赞成。我要把我们拉回正题，聊聊本集和第二个快讯。这是杰夫·布利茨执导的第一集。我们超爱杰夫·布利茨。他执导了11集《办公室》。这是他的第一集。他是一个美妙的、令人愉快的活生生的人。我太崇拜他了。我们联系了杰夫，他发来了关于这一集的音频剪辑。我们太激动了。我还告诉他，我真的很需要他再次作客，因为我们需要讨论《拯救班迪特》。是的。还有当我把那只猫扔进天花板时，这件事必须得谈谈。因为那一集也是他导演的，对吧？是的。但是各位，我想对杰夫
shout out to a movie that Jeff had done. I had watched this movie. It's a documentary. I was a huge fan of it and a fan of his. So I kind of geeked out when he finally got to direct an episode. But he directed a documentary called Spell Bound. It is a fantastic documentary about the script's national spelling bee and it follows eight of the young competitors. It is wonderful. So if you're looking for things to watch, watch Spell Bound. It is so good. It was nominated for an Academy Award. Yes. Oh my god. I forgot that. Yes. It's so good. Well, we asked Jeff, how would you get this job? And I loved his answer. So Sam,
拍过的一部电影表示敬意。我看过这部电影。这是一部纪录片。我是它的超级粉丝，也是他的粉丝。所以当他终于有机会导演一集时，我有点变成了一个极客迷。但他导演了一部名为《拼字比赛》的纪录片。这是一部关于斯克里普斯全国拼字比赛的精彩纪录片，它追踪了八位年轻的参赛者。太精彩了。所以如果你正在寻找观看的东西，去看《拼字比赛》吧。真的太棒了。它获得了奥斯卡奖提名。是的。哦，天哪。我把这事忘了。是的。太棒了。好吧，我们问杰夫，你是怎么得到这份工作的？我非常喜欢他的回答。所以萨姆，
will you play that clip? When Greg was meeting people to talk about directing on the pilot, I got called in to meet with him. He was flirting with the great and probably crazy idea to bring a true doc filmmaker on from the start to kind of overlay a more authentic doc style onto the show. I had just done my first feature doc Spell Bound about kids in the national spelling bee and Greg thought the idea to have me on was an interesting one that he'd explore with NBC who immediately said, not a chance. I think it was almost two years later. I hadn't seen Greg at all and I got a call out of the blue. Greg wanted to know now what I
你能播放那个音频吗？当格雷格在跟人们见面讨论试播集的导演人选时，我被叫去跟他见面。他当时脑子里有一个伟大但可能也很疯狂的想法，那就是从一开始就带一个真正的纪录片电影制作人进来，为这部剧叠加一种更具真实感的纪录片风格。我刚好拍完了我的第一部长篇纪录片《拼字比赛》，讲的是全国拼字比赛的孩子们，格雷格觉得让我加入是个有趣的想法，他会去和NBC探讨这件事，而NBC立刻就说，门儿都没有。我想大概是两年后吧。我压根没见过格雷格，然后我突然接到一个电话。格雷格想知道我现在
like to work on the show. At this point, he thought that he could talk NBC into it. So the office season three, I had my first gig in the world of TV with the episode, The Convict. Yeah. So this was his first scripted television show that he ever directed. He was just coming out of the world of documentary, which I love. I love that Greg did that, right? That he wanted a cinematographer who had shot documentaries. And now he wanted to hire a documentary film director. He was really interested in preserving the integrity of this documentary style for the show. I also love that Greg is such a champion of people. You know, he doesn't
愿不愿意参与这部剧的工作。这时候，他觉得自己可以说服NBC同意了。所以在《办公室》第三季，我在电视剧领域迎来了我的第一份工作，执导的那一集就是《罪犯》。是的，所以这是他导演的有剧本电视剧的首秀。他刚刚走出纪录片的世界，我太喜欢这样了。我喜欢格雷格这么做，对吧？他想要一个拍过纪录片的摄影指导。现在他又想雇一个纪录片电影导演。他真的很有兴趣为这部剧保持这种纪录片风格的完整性。我也喜欢格雷格是一个如此支持人才的人。你知道，他不会
give up on you. NBC said no. He was like, I'm gonna get you in there, Jeff. You know? Yeah. And then he did. I just love that. We also asked Jeff what it was like to shoot his first scripted television show and here's what he had to say. The thing that stood out to me is that I had done all this prep work figuring out all these shots. And, you know, I just had a ton of thoughts about the way each line might be. And then when the shooting actually started, I realized that all the prep work I had done, it just didn't fit for the kind of show that this was. The first or second set up, I think, had me standing right by Pam's desk. And I
轻易放弃你。NBC说不。他当时的想法是：杰夫，我一定要把你弄进来，你知道吗？是的。然后他做到了。我太喜欢这样了。我们还问杰夫，第一次导演有剧本的电视剧是什么感觉，他是这么说的。最让我印象深刻的是，我做了所有的前期准备工作，琢磨了所有这些镜头。而且，你知道的，对于每一句台词的表现方式，我有一大堆想法。然后当拍摄真正开始时，我意识到我做的所有准备工作，根本不适合这种类型的剧集。第一场或第二场布景，我想，我就站在帕姆的桌子旁边，然后我
realized that by then all of the prep work I had done, it just didn't make any sense. And I think that I just, I just dropped all of it into the trash can right there. Well, Angela, I remember Jeff standing at reception for that scene. Yeah. And we really bonded. I felt so fortunate that I got to have him up at reception with me because I just loved him instantly. I feel like reception, you got that sometimes. Like just sitting where you were sitting. A lot of times that directors and writers would be sort of perched up there either on that sofa. You know, they would sit on the sofa right there and watch the scene. And I
意识到，到那时为止我所做的所有准备工作，根本毫无意义。我想我当时就把它们全部扔进垃圾桶里了。好吧，安吉拉，我记得杰夫当时就站在前台为那场戏做准备。是的。我们真的建立起了感情。我感到非常幸运，能让他在接待台陪着我，因为我瞬间就爱上他了。我觉得在前台，你有时会有这种感觉。就像坐在你坐的地方一样。很多时候，导演和作家们会栖息在那里，要么坐在那个沙发上。你知道的，他们会坐在那张沙发上观看拍摄。而我
was a little jealous that you got to have all that time with them. Well, the other thing that used to happen at reception though, Angela, is that people would stand like a wall in front of reception with their back to me. And they would also steal my pens and they would also leave their water bottles on the reception desk. So there's an upside and a downside. There was. There was. All right. Are you ready for Fast Factor number three? I am. Fast Factor number three, Wayne Wilderson, amazing comic actor played Martin Nash. We also reached out to Wayne and he sent in some audio clips about his time on the show. He
有点嫉妒你能和他们有那么多相处时间。好吧，安吉拉，以前在前台还会发生另一件事，那就是人们会像一堵墙一样站在前台前面，背对着我。他们还会偷我的笔，还会把他们的水瓶忘在前台桌子上。所以有得必有失。确实如此。确实如此。好了。你们准备好听第三个快讯了吗？准备好了。第三个快讯，韦恩·威尔德森，了不起的喜剧演员，饰演马丁·纳什。我们还联系了韦恩，他发来了一些关于他在剧组时光的音频剪辑。他
did. Jenna, this time I was sliding into someone's DMs. Oh, I loved it. I loved it. I loved it. Now you and I are just these two ladies in their forties sliding into people's DMs. I know, right? Wayne is fantastic. And we started by asking him how he came to be on the office. And here's what he had to say. Hey, guys, it's Wayne here. How you doing? Thank you so much for letting me come to the party. This is great. I dig the podcast. I'm jumping right into a question one. Can you share how you came to be on the office? Yeah, I got to be on the office. It was just a regular audition call. They had this role was
确实发了。安吉拉，这次我在滑入别人的私信。哦，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。现在你和我就是两个四十多岁滑入别人私信的女人。我懂，对吧？韦恩太棒了。我们首先问他是怎么加入《办公室》的。他是这么说的。嘿，大家好，我是韦恩。你们好吗？非常感谢让我来参加这个派对。这太棒了。我很喜欢这个播客。我直接回答第一个问题。你能分享一下你是怎么加入《办公室》的吗？是的，我能加入《办公室》。这只是一个常规的试镜通知。他们有这个角色
two episodes, working two different weeks. And I already loved the show. And I was a big fan of the British office. So I was very excited for this audition. I knew Steve and I knew Adam just worked with those guys and Evan Almighty. Nancy, Steve's wife is one of my oldest friends, but they swore they had nothing to do with getting the audition. So that's what they said. But I got the job and was super excited. In that particular episode, I'm not sure if I knew when I got the part that Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant had written it. And I think it was the most two episodes were the first ones that they ever did for the U.S.
有两集戏，在两个不同的星期工作。我本来就很喜欢这部剧。而且我是英国版《办公室》的超级粉丝。所以我对这次试镜非常兴奋。我认识史蒂夫，也认识亚当，刚和那些家伙合作过《冒牌天神》。史蒂夫的妻子南希是我的老朋友之一，但他们发誓他们跟这次试镜毫无关系。他们是这么说的。但我得到了这份工作，超级兴奋。在那一集里，我不确定我得到这个角色时是否知道瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·麦克商写了这一集。我想这两集是他们为美国版
office. So that was a that was a bit of a no on. I did not know that he knew Nancy. I didn't either. But it makes sense, right? I mean, they're both really funny, talented people. They were in Boston. I don't know. I know. I see them crossing paths. No, they have the comedy connection and the Boston connection. So yeah, I guess that makes sense. Well, you know, when we were trading emails with Wayne, too, we asked him if he still gets recognized for being on the office. And he said yes, all the time, especially now with the research on Netflix. And he's so tickled by it. But he said it's all young
《办公室》做的最初的两集。所以这算是一个意外之喜。我不知道他认识南希。我也不知道。但这也合理，对吧？我的意思是，他们都是非常有趣、有才华的人。他们在波士顿。我不知道。我知道。我看到他们的生活轨迹有交集。不，他们有喜剧的联系，还有波士顿的联系。所以，是的，我想这说得通。好吧，你知道的，当我们和韦恩互发邮件时，我们还问他是否还会因为出演过《办公室》而被认出来。他说是的，一直都是，尤其是现在Netflix上有这部剧。他对此感到非常高兴。但他
people now. Oh, yeah. I mean, we're crushing it with middle schoolers, guys. Because we talked about this on the merger, he had a big recurring on Veep as well. But I think he gets recognized more for the office, even though it was only two episodes. Oh, Veep is so good. So good. You know, we exchanged a lot of emails with Wayne about this episode. And we were talking about what it was like to rewatch this episode in light of everything that's happening in our country with the Black Lives Matter movement. And here's what he had to say. Wow. I just watched it again. I watched it, you know, maybe
说现在认出他来的都是年轻人。哦，是的。我的意思是，我们在初中生中间火得一塌糊涂，伙计们。因为我们在大合并那一集里聊过，他在《副总统》里也有过很重的常规戏份。但我觉得大家认出他更多还是因为《办公室》，尽管他只演了两集。哦，《副总统》太棒了。太棒了。你知道，我们和韦恩关于这一集交换了许多邮件。我们谈到了在当今我们国家的“黑人的命也是命”运动的背景下，重新观看这一集是什么感觉。他是这么说的。哇。我刚刚又看了一遍。我看了，你知道，可能
every year. So it's such a good episode with everything that's going on in the world now. You know, it feels a little even edgier at some points, but it's super poignant, I guess, for all of the issues that we're dealing with now with race and how we deal with it and what's funny and what's not funny and who can say what when. And, you know, this puts a magnifying glass on where we've been and how far we've come along, what comedy we can do. So it was very interesting. I probably hadn't watched it in a year or so. And to watch it during these times was very interesting. With that, the comedy and its commentary, I think it
每年都看。这是一集非常棒的剧，结合现在世界上发生的一切。你知道，感觉在某些方面甚至更尖锐了，但对于我们现在正在处理的所有关于种族的问题，以及我们如何处理它，什么是有趣的，什么是无趣的，谁可以在什么时候说什么，它都显得超级深刻。而且，你知道的，这把放大镜对准了我们曾经走过的地方，我们已经取得了多大的进步，我们可以做哪些喜剧。所以这非常有趣。我可能有一年左右没看过了。在这个时期看它，真的非常有趣。有了这些，喜剧和它的评论，我觉得它
holds up very well. I think it's kind of a classic office episode. I'm gonna say it's a classic office episode. Boom. Well, Angela, I had not watched this episode since it aired and I definitely found a new poignancy when I was watching it. Oh yeah. And there are definitely lines and moments that stood out to me and I'll bring it up as we go through the episode. Same. Well, why don't we take a break and when we come back, we will break down the convict. We'll see ya. Okay, so we are back. This episode starts with Hannah bringing her baby into the office. She is setting up for her baby staying all day. Clearly, she's got a
经受住了时间的考验。我觉得这算是一集经典的《办公室》。我敢说这是一集经典的《办公室》。太棒了。好吧，安吉拉，自从这集播出后我就没再看过它，我重看时确实发现了一种新的深刻性。哦，是的。确实有一些台词和时刻让我印象深刻，随着我们回顾这一集，我会提出来的。我也是。好吧，那我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来，我们就来剖析《罪犯》。回见。好的，我们回来了。这一集开头是汉娜把她的婴儿带到了办公室。她在为她的婴儿呆上一整天做准备。很明显，她带了
pack-and-play. Yeah, there's a pack-and-play. I mean, she's moving in. What's happening? Yeah, we had a fan question from Ellis Friedman, Victoria Lava, and Megan Keele. Why did Hannah bring her baby into the office? Yes, ladies. Why? Why? We don't know. I watched the deleted scenes. I have a lot to bring to this episode that is explained in deleted scenes. We'll get to that. This is not. There's a whole runner in the deleted scenes with the baby. There's no explanation. People holding the baby. Yeah. I saw that in the script because I have the script for this one and there are all these scenes of people with the
一个便携婴儿床。对，有一个便携婴儿床。我的意思是，她要搬进来了。怎么回事？是的，我们收到了来自埃利斯·弗里德曼、维多利亚·拉瓦和梅根·基尔的粉丝提问。为什么汉娜要把她的婴儿带到办公室？是的，女士们。为什么？为什么？我们不知道。我看过删减片段。关于这一集，有很多在删减片段里解释过的内容。我们待会儿会聊到。这不是。删减片段里有一整条关于婴儿的支线。根本没有解释。人们抱着婴儿。是的。我在剧本里看到了，因为我有这一集的剧本，里面有所有这些人们拿着
baby but never is it explained why the baby is there. I would like to point out that this is a very progressive choice by Michael to allow a new mother to bring their baby into the office for the day, so I appreciate that. Although, what we didn't need him to do was get under the table and do an impression of LaCouse Talking. Do you remember those movies with Kirstie Alley and John Travolta? They were a huge hit. Wait, is Bruce Willis the talking baby? Yeah, Bruce Willis. So, Kirstie Alley has like a one-night stand with this cab driver played by John Travolta and they have a baby and now they have to figure out how to, I guess,
婴儿的场景，但从来没有解释过为什么婴儿会在那里。我要指出的是，迈克尔允许一位新妈妈把她的婴儿带到办公室呆上一天，这是一个非常进步的选择，所以我很赞赏这一点。虽然，我们不需要他做的是钻到桌子底下模仿《看谁在说话》。还记得那些由克尔茜·艾利和约翰·特拉沃尔塔主演的电影吗？它们当时可是轰动一时。等等，布鲁斯·威利斯是那个会说话的婴儿吗？对，布鲁斯·威利斯。所以，克尔茜·艾利和这个由约翰·特拉沃尔塔饰演的出租车司机有了一夜情，他们生了一个婴儿，现在他们必须弄清楚如何，我猜，
co-parent this baby when they're not a couple. Of course, spoiler alert, they're gonna fall in love. Yay. But all the while, you're getting commentary on their parenting and their romance through the voice of the baby voiced by Bruce Willis. As a grown man. So, because he's not doing a baby voice, he's a grown man voice and a baby voice. He's doing his own regular man voice. I want to be in that pitch meeting. I want to be in that pitch meeting. I want to see the person that's like, here's the thing. The baby talks and it's Bruce Willis. The same guy that said Yippee-ki-yay, mother of her, is gonna be the baby. It's gonna be great.
在这个不是情侣的情况下共同抚养这个婴儿。当然，剧透警告，他们会相爱。耶。但与此同时，通过由布鲁斯·威利斯配音的婴儿的声音，你听到了他们对育儿和浪漫的评论。以一个成年男人的声音。所以，因为他不用婴儿的语调，他用的是成年男人的声音和婴儿的声音。他用的是他自己正常的男人声音。我很想加入那个提案会议。我很想加入那个提案会议。我想看看那个提出这个想法的人，就像是：事情是这样的。这个婴儿会说话，而且是布鲁斯·威利斯。那个说过“圣诞快乐，混蛋”的家伙将成为这个婴儿。这一定会棒极了。
Here we go. Okay, well, in the deleted scenes, there is a baby runner. I mean, Karen holds the baby and flirts with Jim and Pam watches it all. I read that in a script. Mm-hmm. Kelly holds the baby and just jiggles it in front of Ryan and Ryan finally is like, what, Kelly? What? Are you holding a baby because you want me to want to have a baby with you? And she's like, no, what are you talking about? Whatever. And then three seconds later, she's like, oh my god, I want a baby right now. It's actually really funny. And then there's a very funny deleted scene where Andy and Dwight have like a baby off. Like, they're so ridiculous. These
开始吧。好吧，在删减片段里，有一条婴儿支线。我的意思是，凯伦抱着婴儿，跟吉姆调情，帕姆在一旁目睹了这一切。我在剧本里读到过。嗯哼。凯利抱着婴儿，就在瑞安面前晃来晃去，瑞安终于忍不住说：干嘛，凯利？什么？你抱着婴儿是因为你想让我想要一个和你生的婴儿吗？而她说：没有，你在胡说八道什么？管他的。然后三秒钟后，她就说：哦，天哪，我现在就想要个婴儿。其实真的很好笑。然后还有一个非常搞笑的删减片段，安迪和德怀特来了一场婴儿大比拼。就像，他们太荒谬了。这
two are so ridiculous. Like, Andy's like, I was a baby model, not gonna apologize for it. I was a beautiful baby and I modeled. This is like their whole competition in the last episode about who has seen more movies. Exactly. So they're arguing about themselves as babies. Andy was, I guess, a gorgeous baby and modeled. And Dwight was like, well, I weighed 13 pounds and my mom couldn't walk for three months. So take that. It's so weird. All right. Well, this scene with Pam having to watch Jim and Karen fuss over this baby was deleted. But the next scene in the episode is Pam watching Jim and Karen kind of flirt at
两个家伙太荒谬了。安吉拉就像是：我以前是个婴儿模特，我才不道歉呢。我以前是个漂亮的婴儿，我还当过模特。这就像他们上一集关于谁看过更多电影的整场竞争一样。完全正确。所以他们在争论自己小时候作为婴儿的事。我猜安迪是个漂亮的婴儿，还当过模特。而德怀特则说：嗯，我出生时重13磅，我妈三个月都不能走路。所以接着吧。太诡异了。好吧。嗯，帕姆不得不看着吉姆和凯伦围着这个婴儿大惊小怪的这场戏被删掉了。但剧集接下来的一个场景是帕姆看着吉姆和凯伦在复印机旁打情骂俏。
the copy machine. Yeah. And at one minute 47 seconds, you can still see my zit from the week before. Stop it. From from the merger. It's a little smaller, but it's still there. You have got to stop pointing it out. None of us noticed or maybe Hadley did because I know she, you know, she noticed Dwight's it. But Jenna, you like to track things. Stop tracking your acne. Well, I think my zit's gonna be gone next week. But I mean, we'll see. We'll see. It'll make your list, I'm sure. All right. So then we have this, you know, Jim talking head and he says that he is seeing Karen. He is. He admits it. But he's ready to talk about it
是的。在1分47秒的时候，你仍然可以看到我前一周长的那颗痘痘。住手。从合并那一集留下的。它小了一点，但它还在。你一定得别再指出来了。我们谁也没注意到，也许哈德利注意到了，因为我知道她，你知道的，她注意到了德怀特的痘痘。但是珍娜，你喜欢追踪这些东西。别再追踪你的青春痘了。好吧，我觉得我的痘痘下周就会消失了。不过我的意思是，走着瞧吧。走着瞧吧。它肯定会进入你的清单的，我敢肯定。好吧。接下来我们有这个，你知道的，吉姆的单人采访，他说他正在和凯伦交往。确实如此。他承认了。但他准备
openly because he doesn't want some people, you know, treating them differently. I have a beef with Jim. I just wrote not cool. Not cool. Yeah. This goes back to my wishy-washy Jim. Yeah, wishy-washy Jim. There it is again. All right. So now we move into the conference room. We've got Angela, Kevin, Michael and Pam. They are all on the speakerphone to Jan. And they are discussing this mysterious check that has arrived. Yeah, I have a question, Jenna. Yeah, I get why Michael's on the phone. I get why the accountants are. Why is Pam there? Is it just because Michael just likes to have Pam around? She's like keeper of the minutes or something. Yeah,
公开谈论这件事，因为他不想让某些人，你知道的，对他们另眼相看。我对吉姆有意见。我刚刚写了：太逊了。太逊了。是的。这可以追溯到我那优柔寡断的吉姆。是的，优柔寡断的吉姆。又来了。好吧。现在我们进入会议室。我们有安吉拉、凯文、迈克尔和帕姆。他们都在免提电话前跟简通话。他们在讨论一张寄来的神秘支票。是的，我有一个问题，珍娜。是的，我懂为什么迈克尔在打电话。我懂为什么会计们也在。为什么帕姆也在？是不是因为迈克尔就是喜欢让帕姆在身边？她就像是会议记录员什么的。是的，
he sees Pam as his personal assistant. She is not his personal assistant. She is the receptionist, but he doesn't have a personal assistant. And so he sort of, you know, makes her play that role. Yeah. She's always in these meetings she shouldn't be in. That's right. Always. There's many episodes of meetings of Pam in conversations between Michael and Jan. And I love it because the camera will just like pan mid scene. And then it reveals Pam has been sitting there with a notebook the whole time. I mean, she's always in these scenes. So awkward. I loved it as an actress. I loved it. I bet. Jan eventually explains that this check is
他把帕姆看作他的私人助理。她才不是他的私人助理。她是前台接待员，但他没有私人助理。所以他有点，你知道的，让她扮演那个角色。是的。她总是出现在这些她不该参加的会议里。没错。总是这样。有好多集的会议里都有帕姆的身影，都是迈克尔和简之间的对话。我太喜欢了，因为镜头会在场景中途摇过去。然后它就会暴露出帕姆其实一直坐在那里拿着笔记本。我的意思是，她总是出现在这些场景里。太尴尬了。作为演员我太喜欢了。我敢打赌。简最终解释说，这张支票是
something that they're getting in exchange for hiring an ex-convict, which Michael is like, I didn't hire an ex-convict. They come to realize that one of the Stanford transfers must be part of this program, meaning that there is someone from Stanford who has a criminal record. All right. So, Jenna, when Jan said, oh, they're probably getting the tax break because they hired an ex-con, I was like, hold up. I know this program. Why did she just jump to ex-con? Because several people qualify for this program because I worked at a company that had employees that qualified for this federal work program. And guess what I did?
他们雇佣一个前科犯所获得的某种补偿，对此迈克尔说：我没有雇佣过前科犯。他们意识到斯坦福转来的员工中一定有人参与了这个项目，这意味着斯坦福来的人里有犯罪记录。好吧。所以，珍娜，当简说，哦，他们大概是因为雇佣了一个前罪犯而得到了税收减免时，我想：等等。我知道这个程序。她怎么直接就跳到前罪犯上去了？因为有几个人符合这个项目的资格，我曾在一家公司工作过，那里的员工就符合这个联邦工作项目的资格。你猜我做了什么？
Well, I'm sensing a deep dive here. Then you sensed right, lady. All right. I went on the U.S. Department of Labor and the IRS websites for like three hours. Real fun stuff there, guys. Real fun. I love you. And I deeply love you for that. I really do, Angela. I love that you did that. I know because this is coming from someone who spent, I think, probably five hours of her life researching an alpha womb. So, go on. Anyway, so it is called the Work Opportunity Tax Credit. It's a federal tax credit available to employees for hiring individuals from certain targeted groups who have consistently faced significant barriers
好吧，我感觉到这里有一个深度挖掘。那你感觉对了，女士。好吧。我去了美国劳工部和国税局的网站，查了大约三个小时。那里真是有趣的内容啊，伙计们。太有趣了。我爱你。我深深地爱你这一点。真的，安吉拉，我爱你。我知道，因为这话出自一个花了我估计人生中差不多五个小时去研究阿尔法子宫的人之口。所以，继续吧。不管怎样，它被称为“工作机会税收减免”。这是一项联邦税收减免政策，提供给雇主，用于雇佣那些在就业方面一直面临重大障碍的特定目标群体中的个人。
to employment. And there are several types of people that qualify for this program. There are veterans, all right. There are recipients of SNAP benefits, which is food stamps, people with supplemental security income, people that have long-term unemployment. So, a lot of people qualify for this, not just ex-cons. And the companies that hire this group, depending on the hours they work, there's like a certain categories they have to check off the list. But your company can get a tax credit anywhere from $2,400 to $9,600 per employee you hire through this program. Wow. Yeah. Oh, am I getting applause for my deep
有几类人符合这个项目的资格。有退伍军人，好吗。还有SNAP福利的领取者，也就是食品券，获得补充保障收入的人，长期失业的人。所以，很多人都符合这个资格，不仅仅是前罪犯。而且雇佣这个群体的公司，根据他们工作的小时数，他们必须在清单上勾选某些类别。但是你的公司通过这个项目每雇佣一个员工，可以获得2400到9600美元不等的税收减免。哇。是的。哦，我的深度挖掘得到掌声了吗？这是一次非常棒的深度挖掘，女士。你很深，你在挖掘，你深深地沉浸在挖掘中。你的歌是什么？你儿子编的。
dive? That was a really well done deep dive, lady. You're deep and you dive and you're deep in a dive. What was your song? Your son made it. You get a deep, you get a dive, put them together, get a deep dive. Well, Angela, I have a beef with Jan, right? Because all of us ask, like, oh, who is it? Who's the ex-convict? And she's like, hold on a second. I'll find out. You'll find out. What? Jan, what are we going to tell this conference room full of people? This, like, private personal, this feels like an HR violation to me. Toby, where are you? Toby, where are you? Jan, you would have to go to a special HR meeting because you just
你得到一个深度，你得到一个挖掘，把它们放在一起，就成了深度挖掘。好吧，安吉拉，我对简有意见，对吧？因为我们所有人都问，哦，是谁？谁是那个前罪犯？而她说：等一下。我会查出来的。你们会知道的。什么？简，我们要对这个满屋子的人说些什么？这，感觉像是一起人力资源违规事件，对吧。托比，你在哪儿？托比，你在哪儿？简，你得去开一个人力资源特别会议，因为你刚刚越界了，女士。我觉得她通过透露这些信息越界了。但在我们等待的时候，每个人都开始猜测到底是谁。迈克尔盲猜，基本上，他们只是看着外面大办公室里能看到的人。
crossed the line, lady. I feel like she crosses the line by giving out this information. But while we are on hold, everyone starts trying to guess who is it. Michael guesses, basically, they're just looking out in the bullpen at who they can see. Hannah, Andy, then Kevin says, Martin, and Michael's like, how dare you? He goes, you just said that because you think Martin is black. And Kevin is like, well, no, he, he is black. So they're kind of bickering about it. And then Jan comes on the phone and she's like, it's Martin Nash. They're all wondering, well, what did Martin do? Yeah, why did he, why was he in jail? And now,
汉娜，安迪，然后凯文说：马丁，而迈克尔说：你怎么敢？他说：你这么说只是因为你觉得马丁是个黑人。而凯文则说：嗯，不，他，他确实是黑人。所以他们就此争论不休。然后简打进电话说：是马丁·纳什。他们都在纳闷，马丁到底做了什么？是的，他为什么，他为什么坐牢？现在，珍娜，我们就要说到迈克尔的那句台词了。你和我讨论过。鉴于“黑人的命也是命”运动，这句话真的让我们感触很深。是的，这就是迈克尔对我们说：黑人在这个国家几乎因为任何事都能被捕。
Jenna, we are coming up to this line that Michael has. You and I talked about it. It really stood out to us in light of the Black Lives Matter movement. Yes, this is when Michael says to us, a black man can be arrested for just about anything in this country. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, we were rewatching this episode in the middle of a civil rights movement in our country. People are literally in the streets protesting this very fact of black people being arrested for just about anything, but not just that being killed. So yeah, this, this line hit me hard. Mm-hmm. And, and I have to say, I expected Michael to make a joke here, but he
是的。是的。我的意思是，我们在我们国家民权运动的中心重温这一集。人们正真真正正地走上街头抗议黑人因几乎任何事情而被捕的这个事实，不仅如此，还有被杀害。所以，是的，这句台词深深地触动了我。嗯哼。而且，我必须说，我原本以为迈克尔会在这里开个玩笑，但他没有。不，他没有。我太高兴他没有这么做。我知道，我也是。好吧，你知道的，我觉得珍娜，作为观众，我们总是期待迈克尔为了镜头而小题大做，对吧？他觉得自己像个艺人，无论如何，但他此刻没有这么做。他只是真实而诚恳。我觉得这让这句台词更有力量了。
doesn't. No, he doesn't. And I'm so glad that he doesn't. I know me too. Well, you know, I think Jenna, as the viewer, we're always expecting Michael to play it up for the cameras, right? He thinks he's like an entertainer and anyway, but he doesn't in this moment. He's just truthful and sincere. And I think it made the line that much more powerful. Yeah, I agree. I agree. And you know, also, and while we were prepping this episode, I was reading the book Just Mercy by Brian Stevenson. And it's, it's an amazing book. It's a memoir. It's about, it's the story of this lawyer, Brian Stevenson, and how he helps to overturn the sentence of a
是的，我同意。我同意。而且你知道，还有，在我们筹备这一集时，我正在读布赖恩·史蒂文森的《正义慈悲》这本书。这是一本很棒的书。这是一部回忆录。它是关于这个律师布赖恩·史蒂文森的故事，以及他是如何帮助推翻一个因未曾犯下的罪行而被判处死刑的男人的判决的。但它也探讨了我们刑事司法系统需要改革的途径。而且它，这是一本非常有力量的书。我觉得我学到了很多。我们实际上可以在我们的节目简介中附上链接，但就在此时此刻重新观看这一集并听到那句台词。我的意思是，它真的，它带给我很多额外的深刻感悟。
man who's on death row for a crime he didn't commit. But it also goes into ways that our criminal justice system is in need of reform. And it's just, it's a really powerful book. And I feel like I learned so much. We can actually, we can link to it in our show notes, but just to rewatch this episode right now and hear that line. I mean, it just, yeah, it had a lot, it had a lot of added poignancy for me. Yeah, for me too. I know Just Mercy is also a movie that's out now, but Jenna, you love the book so much and you're sending it my way. So thank you. I am. Yes, I'm giving you my copy. Thanks. Okay. So getting back to the scene, what
是的，对我也一样。我知道《正义慈悲》也是现在上映的一部电影，但是珍娜，你那么喜欢这本书，你还要把它转送给我。所以谢谢你。不用谢。是的，我把我的那份送给你。谢谢。好吧。所以回到这个场景，接下来会发生什么？好的。所以接下来，迈克尔告诉他们，你知道吗？不要分享这个信息。没有人需要知道这件事。是的。在这个时刻，他出奇地成为了理性的声音。他说，这是别人的私事，分享出去不是件好事，对吧？凯文说，酷。帕姆说，好的。安吉拉对这件事很难接受。
happens next? Okay. So next, Michael tells them, you know what? Do not share this information. No one needs to know about this. Yes. I mean, he's oddly the voice of reason in this moment. He's like, it's no one's business. It's, it's not a good thing to share, right? Kevin says, cool. Pam's like, okay, Angela, have a hard time with that. Angela needs to know what was the crime. Right. And she's also very, you know, she's not a very trusting person. She's a very fear based person. And she starts to spiral out. Well, she's also not a very forgiving person. I mean, don't make a mistake around Angela. She'll remember it forever. And it's no surprise
安吉拉需要知道究竟是什么罪行。没错。而且她也非常，你知道的，她不是一个很有信任感的人。她是一个极度基于恐惧的人。她开始陷入失控。好吧，她也不是一个很懂得原谅的人。我的意思是，千万别在安吉拉周围犯错。她会记一辈子。德怀特有类似的反应我一点也不觉得奇怪，因为他们俩，你知道的，他们是灵魂伴侣。所以他们两个都陷入了失控，但我们待会儿会聊到。好吧。所以接下来，我们来到大办公室，安迪给吉姆打电话。这就是我在卡片上写的内容，珍娜。为什么吉姆还要理会这个对话？他打电话给
to me that Dwight has a similar reaction, because the two of them are, you know, they're soulmates. And so they both spiral out, but we'll get to that. All right. So next, we're out in the bullpen and Andy calls Jim. And this is what I wrote on my card, Jenna. Why does Jim even entertain this conversation? He calls him on the phone because he wants to know which woman in the office he should hit on. And he's like, starts naming all the women. And I agree. Why does Jim not just hang up? I think Jim sort of sees a way to prank Pam. I don't think he wants to be part of Andy's grossness, but he suggests Pam. Yes. So next up, Michael
他，是因为他想知道办公室里哪个女人是他应该去搭讪的。然后他开始说出所有女人的名字。我完全赞同。为什么吉姆不直接挂断电话？我觉得吉姆大概看出了一种捉弄帕姆的方法。我不认为他想参与安迪的低俗，但他建议了帕姆。是的。所以接下来，迈克尔把德怀特拉到一边，告诉他关于马丁的过去。德怀特有一段单人采访，他在其中解释说，他不高兴仅仅是因为他不喜欢罪犯。他不喜欢罪犯。我们收到了来自玛丽·库尔斯、妮可·布里奇斯和杰特·芬顿的粉丝提问。迈克尔告诉德怀特马丁是个罪犯后，他在窗户前有一段单人采访。
takes Dwight aside to tell him about Martin's past. And Dwight has this talking head where he explains that he is upset simply because he does not like criminals. He doesn't like criminals. And we had a fan question from Mary Coors, Nicole Bridges and Jet Fenton. After Michael tells Dwight about Martin being a convict, he has this talking head in front of a window. But normally his talking heads are facing into the office. Why the change now? Okay, people have really been tracking where the talking heads are and the whole window thing ever since we shared about it. So I just want to put this one to rest. This is
但通常他的单人采访都是面对着办公室里的。为什么这次变了？好吧，自从我们分享了关于单人采访的位置和整个窗户的事情以来，人们真的一直在追踪单人采访的位置。所以我只想把这个疑虑彻底消除。这是因为这是那些随性的单人采访之一。这是在我们走进办公室的小堂里，靠近我们的邓德·米夫林标志旁边的窗户。这不是，这不是在会议室里拍的。这不是一个正式的单人采访。如果是的话，我确信他们会把德怀特安顿在那个大办公室为背景的同把椅子上。但既然这是随性的，那就是那个窗户。这并不代表我们之前的单人采访主题。所以象征意义发生在会议室里，而不是随性的单人采访。
because this is one of those on the fly talking heads. This is next to the window that's next to our Dunder Mifflin sign in the little lobby as you walk into the office. This is not, this was not done in the conference room. This was not a formal talking head. If it was, I'm sure they would have sat Dwight down in that same chair with the bullpen behind him. But since this was on the fly, that's what that window is. It is not significant of our previous talking head theme. So the symbolism happens in the conference room, not so much talking head on the fly. Right. So Dwight, like Angela, starts to spiral out with
没错。所以德怀特和安吉拉一样，带着这个信息开始失控。他要设法弄清真相。是的，德怀特和安吉拉都全神贯注于他们不知道马丁为什么坐牢这件事。他们放不下，正如迈克尔所建议的那样。与此同时，安迪正在向吉姆盘问帕姆的兴趣爱好是什么。是的。而吉姆列举了所有这些疯狂的事情。其中有一件，安迪非常感兴趣，那就是frulf，飞盘高尔夫。是的，很明显，吉姆实际上列出了所有帕姆讨厌的事情，但把它们表现为帕姆热爱的事情。他说，任何基于飞盘的比赛。
this information. He's gonna try to get to the bottom of things. Yes, both Dwight and Angela are preoccupied with the fact that they don't know why Martin was in prison. They can't let it go, like Michael suggested. And meanwhile, Andy is quizzing Jim about what are Pam's interests. Yes. And Jim lists off all of these crazy things. One of them, Andy really jumps on, which is frulf, frisbee golf. Yes, it becomes very clear that Jim is actually listing all of the things that Pam hates, but presenting them as the things that Pam loves. And he says, any frisbee based competition. To which Andy says, oh my gosh, I guess he invented
对此安迪说：哦，天哪，我猜他在大学时发明了某种飞盘和高尔夫的结合运动。不，他没有发明。他是那个队的。他在康奈尔大学玩过frulf。安迪没说他发明了frulf。我觉得他说了。我觉得他说他是康奈尔大学frulf队的创始人之一。康奈尔大学的队伍，但不是这项运动的创始人。这是一项真正的运动。不，不，不，安吉拉，等等。是的，它是。我以为那是瞎编的。玩frulf？不。不，根本不存在那种你同时玩飞盘和高尔夫的运动。这不可能是真的。是的，有。住手。
some sort of combination of frisbee and golf while he was in college. No, he didn't invent it. He was on the team. He played frulf at Cornell. Andy doesn't say he invented frulf. I think he did. I think he says he was one of the founders of the frulf team at Cornell. Cornell's team, but not of the sport. It's an actual sport. No, no, no, Angela, wait. Yes, it is. I thought that was made up. Frulfing? No. No, there is not something where you play frisbee and golf at the same time. That cannot be true. Yes, there is. Stop it. Yes, there is, Jenna. So Andy is just saying that he founded the team at Cornell. He is a founding member. I did a
是的，有，珍娜。所以安迪只是说他在康奈尔创立了这支队伍。他是创始成员。我对frulf进行了深度挖掘。而且，我丈夫当时也说：对，飞盘高尔夫。我喜欢飞盘高尔夫。当时我的反应是：等等，什么？他说：对，你在公园里玩。我才没有去谷歌搜索frulf，因为我觉得绝对不可能是真有这东西。这绝对是真的，珍娜。哦，天哪。这是真的。你可以上YouTube。哦，天哪。我上了eHow的YouTube频道，基本上你拿一个飞盘，你必须把它扔进一个篮子里。全国各地都有这样的场地。你实际上可以去职业飞盘高尔夫协会的网站。那是PDGA。你可以在那里找到飞盘高尔夫的地方
deep dive on frulf. Also, my husband was like, yeah, frisbee golf. I love frisbee golf. I was like, wait, what? He's like, yeah, you play it in the park. I did not Google frulf because I thought there is no possible way that is a real thing. It's a real thing, Jenna. Oh my gosh. It's a real thing. You can go on YouTube. Oh my gosh. And I went on the eHow YouTube channel and basically you have a frisbee and you have to throw it in a basket. There's courses all across the country. You can actually go to the Professional Disc Golf Association website. That's the PDGA. And you can find out where there are frisbee golf
深入探讨frulf。而且，我丈夫当时说，对，飞盘高尔夫。我喜欢飞盘高尔夫。我说，等等，什么？他说，对，你在公园里玩。我没有去谷歌搜索frulf，因为我觉得这绝不可能是真实存在的东西。珍娜，它是真的。哦，天哪。它是真的。你可以上YouTube。哦，天哪。我上了eHow的YouTube频道，基本上你有一个飞盘，然后你必须把它扔进一个篮子里。全国各地都有球场。你其实可以去职业飞盘高尔夫协会的网站。那是PDGA。你可以查到哪里有飞盘高尔夫
courses in your area, in your city. And it's a whole thing, Jenna. Wow. Yeah. Well, I just Googled frulf and I'm reading on frulf.com. This is my favorite thing I've read so far. Everyone and everything in the world is part of a frulfing game. Every tree, street, sign, building, car, person, animal, everything is a part of the game. Everything must be taken into consideration when playing a whole. Wow. I have played frisbee golf and I played it like out of college in New York and Central Park and it'd be like, okay, now we weren't on a course like the PDGA where there's like a park with the baskets, but we were just like, okay, the first hole
that you have to get is between those two trees and then you've got to get it onto that fountain and then you've got to get it onto that park bench. You can play frulf anywhere, Jenna. Anywhere. You can play frulf in your backyard. Make your own course, Jenna. It's still so insane to me that there's a part, there's a very, very tiny part of me that is convinced that you have planted all of the frulfing websites on the internet just to like prank me right now. Well, that's, that is absolutely something I would do, not, all right. Wow. Honestly, my mind is blown at that frulfing is a real thing. Okay. Here are
the more of the things that we learn that Pam hates, that Jim presents as things she loves. Hunting adds for six flags with the old man. Do you remember those? I do. I do. It was a guy in like really creepy old age makeup. He wasn't actually old, right? He was covered in this latex makeup and he did this like intense dancing. Yeah. He would like break dance. It was creepy. Yeah. Yeah, it was creepy. And then also Pig Latin. Yeah. I got in a conversation with my husband about Pig Latin. This is when you talk about like bring your work home. Yeah. This was like, I'm like, babe, do you play Frisbee golf? Babe, do you speak Pig
Latin? Apparently, I've been doing it wrong. Shocker, not a shocker. Oh, wait, we had a fan question about this, Angela. Demetria wants to know, can you speak Pig Latin in real life? Angela, you thought you could. Well, my friends and I, we did our version of Pig Latin, but then when I looked it up online, online, it says it's the first two consonants. Okay. And we just did the first letter of each word. That's how we did it. We did the first letter, add it to the end and add a y. But when I looked it up online, it said it's the first two consonants. Is that how you guys do it? Well, what is an example of a word with two consonants?
Psaat. Authe. How would you say Authe? Okay. So my friends and I would say hote. Oh, that's so wrong. Did you guys know what you were saying? Did you guys understand each other? Did you struggle with Pig Latin? No, we had a fine time. We were fine. It was even more secretive for you because other people could not understand your Pig Latin. So how would you say there? Are they? Okay, so we would say herte. Wow. Our way. Well, my friends and I, we actually... Ude, uye. We spoke something called the ob language. It's called the ob language. My friend, Sara O'Haleran's mother taught her the ob language. So Sara's name and ob would be
sabaraba aba haba labarabin. Stop it. That was always my favorite thing to say. That's ridiculous. So you put an ob sound before every vowel sound that you hear. So a word like really is spelled R-E-A, but you don't put ob before the E and before the A. You just put it before the vowel sound. So the word really would be roba lobby. Aba saba roba lobby kabo labengwabij. Aba nmabifraabin. Sabaraba aba haba labarabin. Aba nkabisabignabigabo. Aba n aba labengwabint. Yabas tabus babik dabas. Aba nhabis kabo. Okay, this is ridiculous. And could your friend understand you and speak it back? And would you guys walk around talking like
that? We were so cool. We were so cool. So would my name be abangaba loba? No, your name would be abaladangala. Abalad. Oh my gosh. How do you say Angela? Abangabalaba. Kabanzabi. Kabanzabi. Is that Kinsey? My name is Jabanabafabashabar. Oh my god. That is insane. This podcast is produced by Kabodabishfabashabar and engineered by Sabamkabifabar. All right, all right. Okay, okay. Where are we in this episode? All right, so I have a couple of fan questions from this scene with Jim and Andy. Are you ready? Okay, yeah. Fan question from Sarah Hodges, Liz Franco, Rachel Hayes, and Donna Miller. Are any of the things that Pam hates, things
that Jenna hates too? They want to know, did I get to collaborate on what items Jim chose? No, I did not give any consultation on that list. Clearly, because you had no idea. I had no idea. I don't even know what frothing is. The frisbee golf was a real thing. I hated it, because I didn't know. And then also, we have a mystery. Many people wrote in about this mystery at six minutes and 50 seconds. Christopher Jake, Donna Miller, again, Amy Cruz, and Chelsea K, all wrote in to say, it looks like there is a mini fireplace heater in the background on a desk over Jim's shoulder. What is it? Okay, there really does. I don't know what it is, but I was
mesmerized by it. Mesmerized. Guys, go to six minutes and 50 seconds. What is it? I'm writing this down on a note card, because I want to go check it out. It looks like there is a little heater that has a light, you know, where and then it blows the little, you know, thing to look like a flame. Yeah, it looks like it's sitting on that desk where Luanne always used to sit. Oh my god. Right in front of Toby's desk. One of the things that used to sit on Luanne's desk was a little zingarden. Do you remember? And I wondered if that's what it was. I wondered if there was some light reflecting off of her zingarden. It could be. She had like a
little sand and a ray. Yeah. Okay. So at seven minutes, 17 seconds, Michael does the thing that he does, you guys. He cannot hold on to information. You can't tell him anything. He won't be able to hold on to it. Much like how Michael had to announce to everyone that Oscar was gay, Michael now feels like he's helping. He thinks he's helping. He's just gonna say, Hey, let's just come clean. And you know, he lets everyone know of Martin's past. It's an amazing scene because he walks over to Martin's desk and he's like, Hey, I just wanted to come over and say, like, how are you settling in? And Martin's like, Oh, yeah, thanks for
coming over. I'm settling in fine. And then he immediately says attention, everyone. I just want you to know that Martin is an ex convict, but I trust him and you're not allowed to judge him. And the look on Wayne's face is so amazing because he's he's clearly like, I'm so sorry. I I thought we were making small talk and now apparently we're making a grand announcement about my past. I mean, Wayne's reaction is so good. It's what sells it. And we asked him what it was like to do these scenes with Steve and do these big sort of bullpen scenes. And here's what he had to say. The show at that time was getting hugely popular.
Steve was a huge star, which was just wild because it was just Steve. You know, you're the guy from the FedEx commercials, aren't you? But yeah, I watched the show and I watched the British version as well. I was a big fan of the show. It was really quality work by all people in front and behind the camera. You could tell that you had this feeling it was going to be a historic show and it was going to be around for a long time. So it felt felt really good to be to be a part of it. But walking on set, everybody was so nice, so welcoming. Everybody knew what a great thing they had on their hands. That kind of improv is my favorite
Steve was a huge star, which was just wild because it was just Steve. You know, you're the guy from the FedEx commercials, aren't you? But yeah, I watched the show and I watched the British version as well. I was a big fan of the show. It was really quality work by all people in front and behind the camera. You could tell that you had this feeling it was going to be a historic show and it was going to be around for a long time. So felt felt really good to be to be a part of it. But walking on set, everybody was so nice, so welcoming. Everybody knew what a great thing they had on their hands. That kind of improv is my favorite
improv. That subtle, understated thing that's best done on camera. And everybody there was so good at it and they were already becoming this well-oiled machine. It was nice to jump in and play. So yeah, it's pretty great. I think that's true. I really feel like at this time on the show, we were just this machine, like the cast and the crew and the writers. We had really gelled and as I rewatch it, I can feel that and I can see it. You know what I didn't know, Angela, was that Steve was in those FedEx commercials. Oh yeah. And I went and I googled them and there's like a ton. He was like how
there's like a Verizon guy and then there's flow from progressive. Like Steve was the FedEx guy. Yeah. I did not know this. Are you serious? And I asked Sam to pull a clip. So the Bundcake was bad. The Bundcake was abysmal. But you're missing the point of the story. The entire staff has food poisoning, leaving packages to be shipped, deadlines to be met and one sales manager to do it all. Just one. One. He had the Bundcake. He had the Danish. Stay with me. He jumps on FedEx.com. He's shipping. He's tracking. Getting confirmations on his cell phone. His pagers, PDA. He's got a PDA. Everybody's got a PDA. Nevertheless,
packages arrive, he triumphs over adversity. He's got a PDA. There you go. Well, wait. I have a piece of trivia about that specific FedEx ad that Sam just played. What? I want you guys to know Steve is saying that everyone in the office got food poisoning. The first person that runs to the bathroom to puke in this commercial is Eric Stone Street. What? That's crazy. He's an extra in this commercial and he's running to the bathroom to puke. Eric Stone Street, who's on Modern Family, is in this commercial as a puking employee. I love that. Oh my gosh. That's amazing.
All right. So also in the scene after Michael announces to the entire office that Martin is an ex-convict, he then challenges everyone to name a white man they trust and he will name a black man he trusts even more. So he's like, Pam, name a white man you trust and she says my dad and he says Danny Glover. In the script, there is a Martin talking head and I don't know if this is in the deleted scenes, Angela, but it made me laugh out loud. It was so funny. Martin says, Michael's an all right guy. He told me he trusts me more than Kirsten Dunst and no one's ever told me that before. I love that talking head so much.
There's three sentences, but it is so rich with information and was that in the deleted scenes? Can I see that talking head or no? No, it's not in the deleted scenes and I'm really sad. There is a Martin talking head in the deleted scenes and it's this one. He says, usually when people find out about the prison thing, yeah, they get pretty weird. That's a good one. All right, Jenna, now we're in the break room and we find out why Martin went to prison. Yes, Martin says, do you guys want to know what I was in for? And he explains that he went to prison for insider trading. Now we move into a Kevin talking head that I love. I laughed
out loud. He says, I asked Martin to explain why he went to jail three times because it sounds a lot like what I do every day here at the office. Yes, Jenna, there's a whole theory online that Dunder Mifflin is a front, like a money laundering front. Yes, there is. There is. And that maybe Kevin and I and the accountants are in on it. So here's a fan question from Thomas O'Brien. He says that he knows about this theory and the main reason for this is that Scranton consistently outperforms all the other branches despite the rapidly decreasing paper market. And Thomas wants to know, what do we think about this theory? Do we
think it has any merit that Dunder Mifflin is actually a front for money laundering? I would say no. I don't think it really is a front for money laundering. I mean, if that was a part of the story, I believe Greg Daniels would have revealed that to us in the finale or somewhere in the last season. So no, but I am curious. It does sound like Kevin is participating in some sort of something shady. Yeah, right, because that's what it is. It's insider trading. It's not money laundering. Martin didn't go to prison for money laundering. He went to prison for insider trading. I know, but this is the theory online that
Dunder Mifflin is a front for money laundering. And I'm going to say I could see it. Oh, no, I could see it. I could see it because if you were going to have a money laundering front, by the way, I've also been watching a lot of Ozark, and that's all he does. Okay. If you watch Ozark, he has to launder money for the drug cartel. So I'm like, oh my gosh, yes, a paper company. And you have to, you have like all this inventory and then you have sort of like a boss who's kind of incompetent, who might not catch everything. Right? I think I can see it, Thomas. I can see it. All right. But I'm also watching Ozark. So maybe that's
informing me. All right. Well, in this scene, Martin fields a lot of questions from all of us about what prison was like. And he gives a rather sort of rosy view of prison. He's like, oh, yeah, we had outside time. We got to watch TV. I got to take some classes. Pamela had watercolor classes in prison. And then we're like, wow, Michael, it sounds like prison is better than Dunder Mifflin. You're kind of teasing Michael, right? And then Michael is just very upset at this implication that Dunder Mifflin is worse than prison. What you have to remember is that everyone at Dunder Mifflin is Michael's family and Dunder
Mifflin is like his home away from home. So basically his family has just told him that prison is better than home. Yeah. Prison is better than this world that they've made together. And so Michael is really hurt. Michael had no issue with Martin until right now. And it's because, you know, somehow his employees, which are like his family, think that there's some other cooler place to be. Yeah. And he's like, no, this is the best place to be. You guys, we have it amazing here. And he can't believe that they can't see Dunder Mifflin the way he can. Well, I asked Wayne what it was like to shoot that
break room scene because here he was, he was a guest star and he had to really drive that scene, you know? Yeah. And I mean, I remember what it was like to be a guest actor on shows and how intimidating something like that could be. And so I just wanted to hear what was it like to do this scene from his perspective. Here's what he had to say. Coming to work on your guys. Awesome show. Even though the show was so huge, it wasn't intimidating just because everybody was having like Christmas morning fun, like they couldn't believe they're good fortune. They couldn't believe the people they get to work with
both in front and behind the camera. And they couldn't believe how funny the writing was. So that scene was, I love that scene. I love sort of being the fish out of water getting into the water so everybody can get out of the pool. If that makes any sense, I don't really know what I'm talking about. But yeah, it was an easy environment to do your best work. So yeah, that's, I knew that day like, oh, gotta redo my reel because that's the shizzle. I thought that was the sweetest response. All right, Jenna, I have something to say to you. What? Pamela ding dong. Oh boy. Yeah. So it's 10 minutes, 38 seconds. And Andy is
hitting on Pam in all the wrong ways. No. And the look on Jim's face, it says it all. This is a great prank. It's going great. And then we have the talking head from Pam where she's like, that was, wow. So she loves this prank. She's into it. Well, she's impressed at Jim's ability to prank her in this way. I think she's like, wow, I see where you're going. Now, Jenna, there is a deleted scene where Pam gets him back. Yes, that is in the script. This is a portion of this story that got cut out. There's a bit of a prank war that happens, right? Yeah. Yeah. So Pam gives Andy all this information about all these things that
would just be a horrible night out for Jim, like drinking white Russians, like just going out. Yeah, going to this German restaurant. She basically is like, you know what, Andy? I'm not available, but Jim would love to hang out. He would love a buddy. Yeah. And so Andy's like, what are you doing tonight? We're going out. And Jim's like, whoa, whoa, whoa, wait, wait. So she does get him back. She does. But that did not end up in the episode, which I think is a little bit unfortunate because later when Jim is going to suggest to Andy that he go get his banjo and sing in a high falsetto, that was actually in
response to Pam's prank on Jim. Yeah. So that was like Jim one-upping her. Yeah. But instead, it sort of seems like this one-sided prank. But in the script, it was actually both of them doing it to each other. A two-sided. Yeah. Well, we had a fan question during this talking head, Angela. A lot of people wrote in, Emily Soto, Tori Quill, Angela C, Harshita V, and Monica Jax all said, is the necklace that Pam wears, a horse or a unicorn? Do we know its significance? And do Pam's necklaces represent different periods in her life? Well, guys, it is a unicorn. Mm-hmm. And Pam used to wear a little
heart necklace, but it was a gift from Roy. And so when they broke up, she took it off. And with the wardrobe department, we picked a new necklace for Pam. And this is what we picked. Now, I am curious. I did a deep dive on unicorns. Of course you did. I'm sure my search history on my computer is like IRS, United States Department of Labor, unicorn, unicorn, unicorn. Okay. Why did you guys pick it? And then I'm going to tell you what I found on the internet. We just liked how it looked. Okay. You just liked. We did not assign a particular significance to the fact that it was a unicorn. Okay. Well, lady,
unicorns have been depicted in ancient seals that go back as far as the bronze age, the ancient Greeks. Unicorns are mentioned in the Old Testament of the Bible. What? A symbol of strength. Yes. Unicorns go back to the Bible? Yes. The unicorn is mentioned in the Bible several times. The first verse I found was in Numbers 23, 22. God brought them out of Egypt. He hath, as it were, the strength of a unicorn. I mean, okay. So the unicorn symbol has been around for a long time. It's been associated with strength, fantasy, rarity, purity. It is Scotland's national animal. What? Yeah. When I was in Scotland,
you would see it in places like you go into Edinburgh Castle and it's in the crest, you know? There's also another meaning for unicorn. You might want to take a minute and put some earmuffs on your kids ears. The unicorn is also known as the third woman of a threesome. Oh, it's called a unicorn, which I probably jumped too far on this, but you have Jim, you have Karen, you have Pam. Wow. Is Pam the unicorn? I don't know. I don't know. Okay. I need to reach out to Carrie Bennett in wardrobe and ask her if this unicorn pendant was as arbitrary as I thought it was. Because I like both of your explanations of
unicorn. When you were describing the significance of unicorn, I'm like, yeah, strength, change, perseverance. I'm into it. Right. But then your third woman thing, I don't know. I'm just saying. I'm just saying. It could be. Well, listen, lady, on that note, I think we should take a break and then we will come back and see some of the changes that Michael has instituted at Dunder Mifflin to make life more like prison. Oh, fantastic. All right. So we are back. Michael announces to the group that he is quote, instituting some changes to make this more like prison starting with
one hour of outdoor time. So he makes everyone go down to the parking lot. They're all freezing. One of my favorite things about the scene is that he has two and a half pound weights in his trunk. Yeah. Well, he's not trying to bulk up. No, no, he just wants to tone. We had a fan question from Kali Corrine and Bernadette. When you guys were bundled up and went outside for wreck time in the parking lot, was it actually cold out? No, no, it was not cold at all. I looked it up. We shot this the week of October 2nd. But October is hot in Los Angeles, you guys. It stays really warm. Every October, I get
suckered in to try to recreate like a fall Woodland scene to my front yard. Like I buy all these pumpkins. I have like an autumn wreath. I do this whole thing. And every year, my pumpkins like explode from the heat and turn to mush. And I have to like shovel them off the porch because they're so flattened. Yeah, it was not cold. But I felt like we did a wonderful job of making ourselves look cold. We did great. I was like, Hey, and they put all the ice on the ground and on the cars. Look at us acting. And we look cold. We sold it. All right. So then we go inside to the break room where Michael is setting up
a very sort of grainy television set for Kevin to watch. And Martin shares with him that the TV in prison was a lot bigger. Yeah, yeah. Well, we had a fan question from Graciela, Sydney, Joe, Brooke and Leah. Was the weather forecast that Michael plays on the TV an actual weather forecast from a Scranton newsroom? Or was it an actor? I don't know. Well, lady, I looked this up on the internet and Dunderpedia, if you are correct, you say that it is the actual Scranton weather that it is the NBC weather station. It's WBRE NBC. And that that weather guy is Josh Hodel. Oh, so is that true, Josh Hodel? Is that you?
You know what? That tracks for me. I feel like we would have that detail. I feel like we would. I feel like Phil Shea would have been all over that. Just like all of our menus were local Scranton restaurants, things like that. I feel like Phil Shea would have been on that. I agree. So now should we talk a little bit about how this prank is going? We mentioned it before. Andy is at Jim's desk and Jim's suggesting that he play, you know, the banjo for her and asks if he can sing in a high falsetto. And he's like, you know, I can't. I loved it. It's so funny. Ed is having so much fun in that moment that I loved watching Ed
get to do that. Well, what we didn't talk about is that Karen comes up. Yeah. And she's like, what are you guys doing? What I want in? I want to play. I'll be part of the prank and wishy-washy Jim shows up. He's like, Yeah, because he's caught now. He's caught now. And now if he had to explain this and who she was to him and all their pranking that they did together, now there's accountability and now he's backpedaling. Yeah, exactly. All right, Angela, should we go into the break room so that we can meet one of the most famous characters from the office? This character is so famous.
I mean, Jenna, I love roller skating. Stay with me here. All right. And I have found a community of people who love to roller skate online on Instagram. And I was just sent this gal won a roller skating competition at Prison Mike. It's like amazing. Oh my gosh. I know. It's amazing. I might have to post it. It's so good. I put it in my Insta story, but she is phenomenal. But this character, people love Prison Mike. They love Prison Mike. Jenna, I found the origin story for Prison Mike. What? It's in the deleted scenes. I have to read this to you guys and
made everything make so much sense for me. All right. Okay. Hang with me. I'll look at my notes. Michael Scott has a talking head that's in the deleted scenes. Listen to this. All right. He says, when I was just a little kid, we had an assembly at school where a giant owl came out and gave a very impassioned speech about giving hoots and not polluting. And you know what? I never polluted again. It was right then when I realized the power of saying things as a character. People listen to you when you are wearing an elaborate costume or speaking
in a voice that is not yours. I can't even speak. I... Wow. Michael thinks since he was a little boy that the way you get people to listen to you and make changes is if you are a character. That's how they listen to you. I am so sad that this was deleted because not only does it speak to Prison Mike, it speaks to every character Michael has ever done or ever will do. Because a giant owl told him something and he paid attention. Okay. Wow. He goes on, Jenna. There's another talking head where he says, this isn't the first time
he's done Prison Mike. What? Yeah. He's done Prison Mike before because he developed Prison Mike in improv class. And he said he was in improv class and he was doing a scene and these two college kids, they just wouldn't stop talking. So I became Prison Mike and I turned to them and I said, hey, shut up or I'll stab you twos. Okay. Yeah. Wow. Not only had he done this character before, but he does characters when he wants people to pay attention. This is huge information.
Angela, I know who came up with the idea of Prison Mike in the writer's room. Who? All right. So this script was written by Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant, but we've established before that after a script is written by the original writer or writers it always goes back to the writer's room for punch up and rewrites and that scripts really are a kind of like collaborative effort, right? So when I was watching the scene, I thought to myself, this sounds like BJ Novak to me. Was it? I texted BJ. I was like, BJ, I know
that Stephen and Ricky wrote this episode. Did you come up with Prison Mike? Because I'm putting it on like you or maybe Mike, sure, but I think it's you. Here's what BJ told me. Well, in the lore of the writer's room, I get credit for Prison Mike, but it wasn't me. By the way, I love the writer's room has a lore. I want to know more about the writer's room lore. Well, I'm paraphrasing. I'm not saying lore, but he basically said I have the reputation of having written Prison Mike, but it actually wasn't me. So he
said it was late one night and he was in Paul Lieberstein's office. It was him and Paul and Mindy and they were tasked with having to punch up this scene in the conference room. The idea of the scene was that Michael was just going to convince us all that Dunder Mifflin was better than Prison, but how? And he said that at the beginning of the meeting, Paul kind of offhandedly said, what if he plays a character, you know, like, I don't know, like Prison Mike or something, but they quickly glossed over it and
they kept spitting out ideas and this and that and this and that. And then near the end of the meeting, BJ said something like, well, I really like this idea of him playing a character, Prison Mike, and that Mindy and Paul were like, Prison Mike, that's a brilliant idea. And BJ was kind of like, well, I was really just giving you your own idea back. But somehow he gets credited with Prison Mike. But he said, I think I would give it to Paul Lieberstein. But it was the three of them together that
then wrote those Prison Mike jokes. I love that. And I love that he had the crazy guys and dolls. Yes, that's in the script. Oh my gosh. We actually had a ton of fan questions about this because it's, it's such a good scene. So Kristen went, Jordan C, Gina D, Megan M, Mark M, and many more wanted to know, were any of Steve's lines as Prison Mike improvised? Yes, some, because I looked at the script. But like the main ones, the ones that you remember, like about the gruel and the
dementors, that was all in the script. That was all scripted. There's little moments, like little things that Steve kind of added. But I would have to say for the main points of Prison Mike are scripted. But I feel like we can't do this episode without hearing a little bit of Prison Mike. Agree, Sam. I'm Prison Mike. You know why they call me Prison Mike? Do you really expect us to believe you're somebody else? Do you really expect me to not push you up against the wall,
Biotch? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. That's just the way we talk in the clink. Amazing. Tanks. Tanks. Tanks. Guys, I wrote about this scene in my journal. And I have to tell you guys what I wrote. Oh my gosh. This is kind of a big thing, Jenna, because I said, in the conference room scene when Steve became Prison Mike, the first time he turned around with that bandana on in his crazy guys and dolls accent, we all lost it. Even Steve, which never happens. Because it was so ridiculous.
We all cracked up. And then I said, but if you watch really closely, you can see John and Phyllis are barely holding it together. And if you go to 16 minutes, three seconds, you can see John breaking. I feel like all of us are near breaking through this whole scene. We emailed Jeff Blitz about this. And we were trading messages about this scene. And I said to him, my memory of this was that we were in this conference room doing Prison Mike for like three days. I'm sure it wasn't
that long, but we spent a long time on it. He sent in this audio clip about it. I think for scenes like this, that the goal of it, for me anyway, as you guys well know, I wasn't trying to do it with the most speed. I'm picturing you guys are laughing right now. Yeah, I do. I know that for scenes like this, there's a way to get through it where the whole of the scene gets really boiled down. But something like this, it felt like it needed to, it just intuitively felt like
没那么长，但我们在上面花了很长时间。他为此发来了一段音频。我想对于这样的场景，它的目的，对我来说，正如你们很清楚的那样，我并不是想用最快的速度来拍。我能想象到你们现在在笑。是的，我是。我知道对于这样的场景，有一种拍摄方式可以让整个场景变得非常精简。但像这样的场景，我觉得它需要，直觉上让我觉得
that if I could give Steve more of a run at it, that the whole thought of the scene was just going to come through. So yes, I know. I know for the cast that it was a slog. I know the way I did it was a slog. And yet, man, I love this scene. I do. I just do. I love it. Well, we were all breaking. Wayne emailed us, Jenna, that he broke in the scene as well. And we asked him what some of his favorite moments were. And here's what he had to say.
如果我能给史蒂夫更多发挥的空间，整场戏的意图就会自然而然地流露出来。所以是的，我知道。我知道对于演员来说，这是一段折磨。我知道我拍它的方式是一种折磨。然而，天哪，我太喜欢这场戏了。我是真的很喜欢。我就是很喜欢。好吧，我们当时都在笑场。维恩给我们发了邮件，珍娜，他在那场戏里也笑场了。我们问了他一些他最喜欢的时刻是什么，他是这么说的：
There were a lot of really great favorite moments shooting that episode, the convict and shooting the one before that, the merger, the moment with Stanley was great. But the one I remember most is obviously the whole prison Mike thing was hilarious. And take after take, you know, it was so very hard to not break while Steve was doing prison Mike and we broke a lot. And then that conference room, it was pretty hot. I remember had to get wiped down for sweat a lot. But there's
拍摄那一集时有很多非常棒的最喜欢的时刻，也就是“罪犯”那一集，还有拍摄它前面那一集“公司合并”时，和斯坦利在一起的时刻非常棒。但我印象最深的显然是整个“监狱迈克”的桥段，简直太搞笑了。一个镜头接一个镜头，你知道的，当史蒂夫在扮演“监狱迈克”时，要忍住不笑真的太难了，我们笑场了好多次。然后那个会议室里，相当热。我记得经常得擦汗。但
one moment towards the end of his prison Mike routine. And they use this particular take in the episode, I believe, where he goes and thanks for letting me be a potty of life because you got a good life. You got a good life. And that was the first time he had done the second you got a good life. And the camera is behind me and you can see my cheeks bulge because I'm about to explode with laughter. I don't want to ruin the take. But that whole day in the conference room with prison
在他的“监狱迈克”常规表演快结束时有一个时刻。我相信他们在剧里用了那个特定的镜头，就是他说“谢谢你让我成为生活的一部分，因为你过得很好。你过得很好。”那是他第一次加上后面那句“你过得很好”。摄像机在我身后，你能看到我的脸颊鼓起来，因为我快要笑得喷出来了。我不想毁了这个镜头。但我不得不说，在会议室里跟监狱迈克
Mike was pretty special, I have to say. Yes. And by the way, I looked at that moment he's talking about and you totally can see him smiling. It's like on the back of his head and you know he's smiling. It's one of those. That's how funny the scene was to us when we were shooting it. I rewatched that with him in mind as well and just you got a good life. It just made me laugh. It did really make me laugh that he remembered how hot the conference room was because
在一起的那整整一天都非常特别。是的。顺便说一句，我看过他说的那个镜头，你绝对能看出他在笑。就像是在他后脑勺上，你知道他在笑。就是那种情况。我们在拍摄时，这个场景对我们来说就是这么搞笑。我带着他的感受重新看了那一幕，听到“你过得很好”时。真的让我笑出声了。他记得会议室有多热，这确实让我笑得很开心，因为
Jenna, the guys hated the conference room because they would get so hot. It was the one place where my body temperature actually felt okay. Yes, same. That was something about conference room scenes that I loved. I knew I wasn't going to be cold. Yes, we knew we wouldn't freeze to death. But meanwhile, the guys were like a sweaty mess. So that made me laugh. We had a fan catch in this scene as well from Allison Kamada. She says around 14 minutes and 23 seconds
珍娜，这群男士讨厌会议室，因为里面会变得非常热。那是唯一一个让我的体温感觉还算正常的地方。是的，我也是。会议室的戏有一点是我特别喜欢的。我知道我不会挨冻。是的，我们知道我们不会冻死。但与此同时，那些男士们却热得像大汗淋漓的乱麻。所以这把我逗笑了。艾莉森·镰田（Allison Kamada）在这一集中也捉到一个穿帮镜头，她说大约在14分23秒时
when everyone's in the conference room, I saw like someone's knee in a pair of shorts and boots. Was this the camera operator? Yes. Who? Randall or Matt? I think it was Randall. So it's right after Prison Mike asks you, Angela, if you really expect him not to push you up against the wall, that clip we played, the camera widens out to show the whole group sort of being like, hey, whoa, whoa, whoa. If you look in the far right corner, I think you can see Randall's
当大家都在会议室里时，我看到好像某人的膝盖，穿着短裤和靴子。这是摄像师吗？是的。谁？兰德尔还是马特？我觉得是兰德尔。就在监狱迈克问你，安吉拉，你是否真的指望他不把你推到墙上之后，也就是我们播放的那个片段，镜头拉宽，显示出整个群体好像都在说：嘿，哇，哇，哇。如果你看最右边的角落，我想你能看到兰德尔的
knee because I think he's like perched in the corner there and he's got his camera on Steve and then Matt probably had his camera on you and the group. Yes, because Matt would get reactions and Randall would have Steve and yes, you are right. I bet it's Randall's knee. That's a great catch. Yeah, I thought so too. I thought so too. So the group is not sort of giving Michael what he wants. No. So he resorts to locking them in the conference room. He's like, if you want to feel
膝盖，因为我觉得他就像蹲在那个角落里，他的摄像机对着史蒂夫，然后马特可能把摄像机对准了你和大家。是的，因为马特负责拍大家的反应，兰德尔负责拍史蒂夫，是的，你说的对。我敢打赌那是兰德尔的膝盖。真是个绝佳的发现。是的，我也这么觉得。我也这么觉得。所以大家并没有顺着迈克的心思走。不。于是他采取了把他们锁在会议室里的手段。他说，如果你想感受
what it feels like to be imprisoned, here you go. And he walks out of the conference room. Now here's a little something. That is such a fakey fake lock. That door did not lock at all. I don't even think it shut very well. I also think that if you look at it, you can see that like Steve is doing a bit of sleight of hand. I don't even think the key goes in the keyhole. I don't think that that keyhole has always been locked in there. Well, now I can't be sure because I know
一下坐牢是什么滋味，那就给你们尝尝。然后他走出了会议室。现在这里有个小细节。那锁假得太离谱了。那扇门根本就没锁上。我甚至觉得它关得都不是很好。我还觉得，如果你仔细看，你会发现史蒂夫在玩一点障眼法。我甚至不认为钥匙插进了钥匙孔。我不认为那个钥匙孔一直是锁着的。好吧，现在我不能确定了，因为我知道
that Jim locks Dwight in there. Yes, Jim, it's not the first time someone's been locked in there. Dwight was locked in there. But in that one again, I meant to point out that it looks like there's nowhere to lock anyone in. Yeah, there's no keyhole. I see no possible way that Jim actually locked him in there. It looks it's all very fakey fake sleight of hand. Alright, where are we? Where are we? We're locked in the conference room. Pam calls Toby. Pam called Toby and
吉姆把德怀特锁在里面过。是的，吉姆，这已经不是第一次有人被锁在里面了。德怀特就被锁在里面过。但在那个镜头里，我还是想指出，看起来根本没有地方可以把人锁起来。是的，没有钥匙孔。我觉得吉姆根本不可能把他锁在里面。看起来这完全是虚假的障眼法。好吧，我们到哪了？我们到哪了？我们被锁在会议室里了。帕姆给托比打电话。帕姆给托比打了电话，
Toby explains to Michael, Michael, they're just teasing you. Of course they know that prison is worse than Dunder Mifflin. They'll look on his face when he realizes he's being teased. He like he immediately forgives everyone and he's just so delighted to be part of a joke. Exactly. He's like, oh, they do get it. They do like it here. They do like me. They are happy here. It's a joke. Oh, I get it now. So now Michael has a talking head and he explains
托比向迈克解释，迈克，他们只是在逗你玩。他们当然知道监狱比邓德米夫林糟糕。当他意识到自己被捉弄时，他脸上的表情。他就像是立刻原谅了所有人，而且他能成为笑话的一部分简直太高兴了。没错。他就像是，哦，他们确实懂。他们确实喜欢这里。他们确实喜欢我。他们在这里很高兴。这是一个笑话。哦，我现在明白了。所以现在迈克有一个单人访谈，他解释说
that Martin has quit. And Jenna, do you blame him? I mean, no, I don't blame him like how do you work there now? And also you have to remember this fulfills a story arc for the show that each week, a Stanford employee is going to go. Yeah. Well, I noticed something. When Martin is leaving, he's getting into the elevator and you see him. He's carrying his box of things. Meredith is walking out of the elevator back into the office. And that made
马丁辞职了。珍娜，你怪他吗？我是说，不，我不怪他，换作你怎么还在那儿工作？而且你得记住，这完成了剧集的一个故事线，即每周都会走掉一个斯坦福的员工。好吧，我注意到了一件事。当马丁离开时，他正在上电梯，你看到他了。他搬着装东西的箱子。梅雷迪思正从电梯里走出来回办公室。这让我
me realize, wait a second. She was not in the prison mic scenes in the conference room. No. And then we got a fan question from Joy Moran that says, wait, where was Meredith all this time? Is there a deleted scene that explains why she's so late to work? Angela, please help me enjoy out. All right, ladies, there is a whole runner in the deleted scenes and it explains all of this. So Meredith says that her car is in the shop and she needs a
意识到，等一下。她根本不在会议室里那些“监狱迈克”的场景中。没有。然后我们收到了乔伊·莫兰（Joy Moran）的一个粉丝提问，上面写着：等等，梅雷迪思这一路都在哪？有没有删除的片段来解释她为什么上班迟到这么久？安吉拉，请帮我解答一下乔伊的疑问。好吧，女士们，删除的片段里其实有一整条支线剧情，解释了这一切。所以梅雷迪思说她的车在修理厂，她需要
ride to go get it. And Martin offers to give her a ride. Dwight and Angela, because they are so suspicious of Martin and why he went to prison, they have this whole like sort of like, I don't know, like their detectives on the case. They have a whole runner as well. But Meredith goes to get her car out of the shop. So that's where Meredith is. Yeah. I feel, I feel bad for Kate that she wasn't in the car. I know. That's what I thought
搭车去取车。马丁主动提出载她一程。德怀特和安吉拉因为对马丁以及他为什么坐过牢产生怀疑，他们有一整条类似于，我不知道，就像他们在案子里的侦探一样的支线剧情。他们也有整条支线。但梅雷迪思去修理厂取车了。所以梅雷迪思就在那里。是的。我为凯特感到遗憾，她没能坐在车里。我知道。我也是这么想的，
too, Jenna. I was like, oh my gosh, Kate didn't get to sit in there and have to bite the inside of her mouth so she didn't laugh out loud at prison mic. I thought the same thing. Cause you got a good life. You got a good life. All right. So now we have the final scene. Andy is playing the banjo for Pam and singing Rainbow Connection in a high falsetto. A lot of people wrote in about this scene. Let's hear it. What'd they
珍娜。我想，哦天哪，凯特没能坐在那里，不得不咬着嘴唇内部以免在“监狱迈克”面前笑出声来。我也是这么想的。因为你过得很好。你过得很好。好吧。现在我们来到了最后一个场景。安迪在为帕姆弹班卓琴，并用高假声唱着《彩虹的连接》（Rainbow Connection）。很多人写信来谈论这个场景。让我们听听。他们说了什么？
say? Okay. Leslie G, Ashley G, Ava H, Alyssa C, and Carrie C all said, Jenna, how did you get through that scene at the end when Ed is singing to you? Did you ever break and laugh? Yes. Like a million times. But I have to say something. I love the banjo. I love the banjo and you and I, Jenna, have talked about this a lot and we've told Ed that some of our fondest memories on set with him are
好吧。莱斯利·G（Leslie G）、阿什利·G（Ashley G）、艾娃·H（Ava H）、阿丽莎·C（Alyssa C）和凯里·C（Carrie C）都说，珍娜，当埃德对你唱歌时，你是怎么熬过最后那个场景的？你有没有笑场？是的。就像一百万次一样。但我必须说点什么。我喜欢班卓琴。我喜欢班卓琴，你和我，珍娜，对此讨论过很多次，我们曾对埃德说过，我们在片场和他在一起最美好的回忆之一，就是
when he would get out the banjo and Creed would get out his mandolin and they would play. I did not want this scene to end. Yeah. This was very funny. As Jenna, I had to love a prank and hate the banjo, but in real life I hate a prank and I love the banjo. So I loved doing this scene and I didn't want it to end and we filmed it at the end of, I think we filmed it at the end of the
当他拿出班卓琴，克里德拿出他的曼陀林琴时，他们会一起演奏。我真不想让这个场景结束。是的。这太搞笑了。作为珍娜，我必须讨厌恶作剧却喜爱班卓琴，但在现实生活中，我讨厌恶作剧却喜爱班卓琴。所以我很喜欢拍这个场景，我不想让它结束，我们是在——我想我们是在周末结束时拍摄的。
week. And so it was, again, one of those scenes where there weren't many people around. It was just a few of us and it always felt like you could take all the time in the world when that was the case. No one was waiting on you. And it's one of my fondest memories is doing that scene with Ed. I loved it. So we asked Jeff Blitz what it was like to shoot the scene and this is
所以它再次成为那种周围没多少人的场景。现场只有我们少数几个人，当遇到这种情况时，总会觉得你可以拥有全世界所有的时间。没有人等著你。这是我和埃德一起拍摄那个场景最美好的回忆之一。我太喜欢了。所以我们问杰夫·布里茨（Jeff Blitz）拍摄这个场景是什么感觉，他是这么说的：
what he had to say. So that final scene, that song, I loved that too. I loved it so much. I loved it for Andy. It's so sweet and for Pam, it's so bad, but it's so sweet also. I don't know. Boy, you know, I will say about it though. I think it was about trying to figure out to what extent should it be such... The funnier the song is, it just means that Andy's sense of himself
所以最后一个场景，那首歌，我也非常喜欢。我太喜欢了。我为安迪感到高兴，它太甜美了，对于帕姆来说，这太糟糕了，但同时也太甜美了。不知道为什么。天哪，你知道的，不过我要说的是。我认为这是关于弄清楚它应该达到什么程度……这首歌越搞笑，就越意味着安迪的世界观
in the world has changed by that. So I do think there was a lot of talk about it there, you know? So Angela, something that I noticed in the script about this scene is that Jim is not in that scene. It's just in the script Andy playing the banjo for Pam. And it's so beautiful the way it is now, right? That you have this rack focus from Pam looking to Jim and then Jim looking to
因此发生了改变。所以我确实认为当时有很多关于这方面的讨论，你知道吗？所以，安吉拉，我在剧本中关于这个场景注意到的一件事是，吉姆并没有出现在那个场景中。剧本里只是安迪在为帕姆弹班卓琴。现在呈现出来的效果是如此美丽，对吧？你从帕姆看着吉姆，然后吉姆看着镜头，有一个移焦。
camera. It's perfect. And I asked Jeff about it and he said, yeah, that was his idea to add Jim at the end. He actually said that he forgot to tell everybody that that was his idea and on the day they had like started to send John home and they had to like get him back. Yeah, they had to be like, he said it was a little bit of a mess with his schedule. Here's
这太完美了。我问了杰夫这件事，他说，是的，在结尾加入吉姆是他的主意。他实际上说他忘了告诉所有人那是他的主意，那天他们甚至已经开始准备让约翰回家了，然后他们不得不把他找回来。是的，他们不得不这样，他说他的日程安排有点乱。他是这么说的：
what he said. He said, I really do love revealing Jim there, enjoying the lunacy of what he's put Pam through. And in a weird way, even though it's heavily ironic and played off as a joke, this is the closest Jim can come in that moment to serenading Pam himself. Aw, yeah. Well, yeah, to me, that moment doesn't work without Jim there because that final
他说，我真的很喜欢在那里展现吉姆，享受他给帕姆带来的这场疯狂。用一种奇怪的方式，尽管它带有浓厚的讽刺意味且被当成一个玩笑，但这已经是吉姆在那个时刻能做到的、最接近亲自向帕姆唱情歌的举动了。噢，是的。好吧，是的，对我来说，如果没有吉姆在那儿，那个时刻就无法成立，因为最后那个
moment is him and Pam getting to flirt and have a connection. Yeah, they just now have to do it through a conduit. Like once again, they can't like communicate to one another because there's other people in the way. So they have to find ways around it. Yeah, that was all Jeff Blitz. I love all of these audio clips, Jenna, that Jeff gave us and Wayne and they really just open up
时刻是他和帕姆能够调情并建立联系。是的，他们现在必须通过一个媒介来实现这一点。就像他们再次无法直接交流一样，因为中间有其他人挡着。所以他们必须找到绕过障碍的方法。是的，这全都是杰夫·布里茨的主意。我喜欢杰夫和维恩给我们的所有这些音频片段，珍娜，它们真的为我打开了
the episode for me so much. And I don't know if you guys heard this and it's something Jeff will go on to talk about, but Jeff has a stutter. And he was a little nervous about making the audio clips. Then he actually sent in this audio clip that we want to play for you about how he felt like his stutter was an advantage to him. Here, listen to what he has to say.
这一集的视野。我不知道你们有没有听到这个，杰夫接下来会谈到这一点，但杰夫有口吃。他对于制作音频片段有点紧张。然后他实际上发来了这段音频，我们想放给你们听，关于他如何觉得自己的口吃对他是种优势。来听听他是怎么说的。
As a side note, I want to say this, that the stuttering thing, which I'm sure that is coming through loud and clear for some of this stuff, it is part when I started working with you guys, I was so scared that the stuttering was going to make it such that when I wanted to share notes with you that I would, that the amount of time it would take to do it and then I'd be embarrassed
顺便提一句，我想说的是，口吃这件事——我相信某些内容听起来非常清晰——它是我开始和你们合作时的一部分，我当时太害怕口吃了，以至于当我想要和你们分享意见时，我需要花那么多时间来表达，然后我会感到尴尬，
and all that stuff. But anyway, I do think it inspired something where like, rather than shout notes out to the cast that I would go and that for me it just, it felt like a better thing to not do that. And so I think it turned into something where the note had like a thoughtfulness to it and I could talk to people about it and it felt like I could spin it in a
诸如此类的事情。但无论如何，我确实认为它激发了一些东西，比如与其对着演员大喊大叫地提意见，不如……对我来说，这样做感觉更好一些。所以我认为它变成了一种让意见带有思考性的东西，我可以和大家谈论它，感觉我可以把它扭转成一种
way that it made that for me anyway feel like a good thing. It's not as good on a podcast, I'm sorry, but anyway, yeah, just wanted to say that. Well, it's interesting, Angela, because my memories of working with Jeff are of close intimate conversations that were very connected. Yeah. And so I never found his stutter to get in the way of connecting with him. In fact,
对我来说无论如何都觉得是一件好事。在播客里效果可能没那么好，我很抱歉，但无论如何，是的，只想说这些。好吧，这很有趣，安吉拉，因为我对与杰夫合作的记忆是那种非常紧密的、亲密的对话。是的。所以我从未觉得他的口吃妨碍了与他的交流。事实上，
I think he's right, I think it actually created a deeper connection because we had these one on one conversations. Yeah. My memories of being around Jeff are of these quiet intimate conversations coupled with laughing harder than I've ever laughed. Yes. Yeah. I absolutely agree with that. And that's why I cannot wait to tell the story
我觉得他是对的，我认为这实际上创造了更深的连接，因为我们有过这些一对一的对话。是的。我对和杰夫在一起的记忆是这些安静、亲密的对话，伴随着我这辈子经历过的最疯狂的笑声。是的。是的。我完全同意这一点。这就是为什么我迫不及待地想和杰夫一起讲述
of Save Bandit with Jeff because it was me and Jeff and Kent and Greg on set that day when we rehearsed it, getting the cat in the ceiling. I'm not going to get into it, but let me tell you, I am living for that podcast because I want all of them. I want us all to retell the story. Oh my gosh, we should get all you guys to come together and we should do a
“拯救小狗班迪特”（Save Bandit）的故事，因为排练那天在片场把猫弄进天花板里的只有我和杰夫、肯特还有格雷格。我不会深入展开，但实话告诉你们，我为了这个播客而活，因为我想要他们所有人。我希望我们所有人重新讲述这个故事。哦天哪，我们应该让你们所有人都聚在一起，我们应该做一个
special Save Bandit where everyone speaks their memories of that scene. A Save Bandit deep dive. Yes. Yes. I love that. Well, guys, we also have a final audio clip from Wayne Wilderson. He's just letting us know a few of the things he's doing now and where you can find him. Well, I did upload on Amazon Prime with Greg Daniels.
特别的“拯救小狗班迪特”节目，每个人都讲出他们对那个场景的记忆。一个深入探讨“拯救小狗班迪特”的节目。是的。是的。我太喜欢了。好吧，伙计们，我们还有维恩·威尔德森（Wayne Wilderson）发来的最后一段音频。他只是让我们了解了他现在正在做的一些事情以及你在哪里可以找到他。嗯，我和格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）在亚马逊Prime（Amazon Prime）上制作了节目。
I know they've been picked up for a second season, so hopefully we'll be seeing me back on that. You can go find reruns of work I did with another office alum, Randall Einhorn, where I played the principal on the mic. And yeah, oh, where can you find me? On Twitter, I'm Wayne Wilderson, one word. On Facebook, I'm Wayne Wilderson, one word.
我知道他们已经续订了第二季，所以希望大家能在上面再次看到我。你可以去重温我与另一个办公室校友兰德尔·艾因霍恩（Randall Einhorn）合作的作品，我在里面扮演了那个用麦克风的校长。是的，哦，你在哪里可以找到我？在推特（Twitter）上，我是维恩·威尔德森，一个词。在脸书（Facebook）上，我是维恩·威尔德森，一个词。
And on Instagram, I'm Wayne Wilderson. That's one word. You guys miss you? Thank you so much for letting me come on your awesome podcast. It's been a lot of fun. All right. Later. He makes me laugh. The way he was setting that up, I thought he was going to say something different for his Instagram, but I know his Instagram is
在Instagram上，我是维恩·威尔德森。那是一个词。你们想我吗？非常感谢让我来到你们这个精彩的播客。这真的非常有趣。好吧。回见。他把我逗笑了。他刚才那样说的时候，我还以为他会在Instagram上说点别的，但我知道他的Instagram就是
Wayne Wilderson, one word. Yeah. Anyway, by the way, it's not Wayne Wilderson, one word. It's just Wayne Wilderson. Yeah. One word. Exactly. It is his name combined, guys. And you can find Jeff Blitz on Twitter at Jeffree Blitz. Jeff, Wayne, thank you so much. Guys, that was the convict.
维恩·威尔德森，一个词。是的。不管怎样，顺便说一句，不是维恩·威尔德森，一个词。只是维恩·威尔德森。是的。一个词。没错。这就是他的名字连在一起，伙计们。你可以在推特上找到杰夫·布里茨，账号是杰夫·布里茨（Jeffree Blitz）。杰夫、维恩，非常感谢你们。伙计们，那是“罪犯”那一集。
That was the convict. Thank you so much for listening and sending in your questions. We will see you next week with part one of Phinney Hanna Christmas. It's Christmas already, and it's going to be a two-parter. And we have guests. Oh, we're excited. See you next week. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
那是“罪犯”那一集。非常感谢你们的收听和提问。我们下周将带着《菲尼和汉娜的圣诞节》（Phinney Hanna Christmas）的第一部分与大家见面。圣诞节已经到了，而且这将是一个两集连播。我们还有嘉宾。哦，我们太激动了。下周见。再见。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。
Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。